en la larga y bastante dilatada vida
política de nancy pelosi taiwán y los
asuntos de china han sido un elemento
central recordemos que en 1991 dos años
después de los sucesos de la plaza de
tiananmen
nancy pelosi fue a beijing y expuso de
manera directa un mensaje que hacía
alusión a la importancia de difundir la
democracia en la república popular china
y por lo tanto desde ese momento ha sido
vista con suspicacia como lo mencioné
anteriormente en efecto como usted lo
menciona la competencia del siglo 21
será una competencia ardua sin pausa
constante dinámica entre las principales
potencias a nivel global y sin duda
alguna la presencia de eeuu en corea del
sur en japón y por supuesto en cualquier
otro país va a ser
una competencia política diplomática y
económica y comercial acá hay un
elemento que no hemos mencionado y es
recuerde usted que taiwán es uno de los
principales productores de
semiconductores a nivel mundial y este
elemento es fundamental para asegurar
las cadenas de valor global para
asegurar la producción de muchos bienes
de alta tecnología que se llevan a cabo
con tecnología estadounidense en taiwán
o en otros lugares de asia entonces este
tuit sin duda alguna tiene una intención
manifiesta y es incomodar a nivel
interno pero al mismo tiempo
generar esa presión que eventualmente el
ejecutivo no puede llevar a cabo en este
momento joe biden y el secretario de
estado anthony blinken han sido
relativamente
mesurados en el enfoque que quieren
llevar hacia china no quieren que sea un
enfoque al estilo donald trump de
ataques indiscriminados de falsas
palabras de un torno al uso en los
medios de comunicación quieren que se
lleve a cabo de una manera distinta
diplomática y tal vez nancy pelosi tiene
en este momento como líder demócrata en
la cámara de representantes de ser mucho
más agresiva desde su llegada al
monetariamente la bienvenida y por lo
tanto para llevar a cabo una una mucho
más abierta oposición a la república
popular china